salut brut mois ses chars le travail
j'ai 26 ans je suis belge ces
photographes réalisatrice et je vais
vous montrer un super projet sur le sexe
[Musique]
m
je vais vous montrer la campagne
d'affichage qui a d'ailleurs lieu dans
toute la france qui fait la promo donc
du petit manuel de sex education pour la
sortie de la fonde
[Musique]
voilà mon première il ya encore un gros
tabou sur les règles bon ça va de mieux
en mieux heureusement mais voilà déjà le
fait que dans les pubs se soit montrée
sous un liquide bleu qu'en gros du sang
qui coule du nez c'est cool mais du sang
qui coule de la chatte c'est moins cool
mais c'est normal
ceci est normal donc c'était important
aussi de comment dire de l'introduire
dans l'espace public parce que c'est
quelque chose de normal à voir donc
c'est aussi normal de voir dans métro
est éteint
une des autres affiches de la campagne
qui fait partie du chapitre épisode qui
est sur les orientations sexuelles qui
du désir qui tu veux
et qui parle forcément
orientation sexuelle qui par les
chiffres des sexualités est-ce que
c'était important aussi de dire que la
sécurité c'est une orientation sexuelle
c'est le fait de ne pas avoir de désir
sexuel de pavant pas ce que c'est
sexy et c'est juste une orientation
commune ont donc la simple beauté
l'amour et
je pense qu'il a suscité déjà pas mal de
réactions sur la page facebook de
netflix a connaît les homophobes
n'oubliez jamais que l'homophobie n'est
pas une opinion c'est un délit c'est
illégal et ça tue des gens
l'éducation sexuelle c'est un truc qu'on
a presque pas à l'école c'est un truc on
pas toujours moyen de parler avec ses
parents voire très peu eu
du coup comme ressource ya quoi il ya le
porno c'est pas ouf voilà là c'était
vraiment l'occasion elle pouvoir dire
voilà on placarde ça dans l'espace
public pour amener un débat sur la
sexualité
et sûr
et sur ce qu'on se connaît ou si on ne
connaît pas le sexe ça ouvre le débat
parce que c'est assez
inhabituel ou parce que ça parle des
choses de un type sur la sexualité c'est
le rapport intime avec le corps le désir
et restera donc c'est un truc très
privée et qu'on met dans l'espace public
quoi mais au final qui est privé mais
qui est aussi politique parce que ça me
concerne tous
[Musique]
affiches représentent pour ceux qui ne
le savent pas et celle pour le papa un
clitoris
je suis chaud il ya plein de gens y
pensent et des poumons ou bien tu vois
même moi je pense que j'ai découvert
vraiment sa forme qui est celle ci que
que quand j'avais jour 22 23 ans alors
que j'avais un clitoris depuis ma
naissance et je pense qu'il ya
énormément de personnes qui ne savent
pas à quoi ressemble un clitoris même
des personnes qui ont un credo rice et
et que c'est c'est vraiment savoir que
c'est un organe qui entièrement dédié au
plaisir
donc c'est le seul organe en fait du
corps humain qui avait déplu au plaisir
donc c'est vrai qu'il
[Musique]
c'est qu'il ya une culotte quelque part
que tu regrettes
[Musique]
voilà voilà une petite culotte qui
évoque le premier chapitre du petit
manuel de sex education qui parle du
consentement
parce que non c'est le but
un couteau qui se battre à l'avant
[Musique]
je fais des photos depuis que j'ai 13 14
ans et
donc
j'avais toujours une notion de
l'injustice faite aux femmes est de
vouloir représenter des jeunes filles
des jeunes fans de mon entourage et au
fur et à mesure que j'ai grandi que je
me suis intéressé au monde extérieur à
la société et tout ça bah je me suis de
plus en plus intéressés en fait au
féminisme dans différents projets que
photos et vidéos en vidéo ça a pu être
par le clip dépassant de joie sens où le
clip d'angel balance son corps j'essaye
de faire passer des messages ou au moins
de vue soulevé des interrogations parce
que j'ai pas la prétention de dire que
j'apporte des réponses mais juste voilà
questionner un peu les représentations
les normes
c'est là qu'on se rend compte notamment
avec cette campagne d'affichage en fait
que que le les images elles ont un vrai
pouvoir d' influence un vrai pouvoir de
d'amener des débats sur la table et de
faire se poser des questions réfléchir
et
par importance et c'est le pouvoir de
l'image c'est dans ce havre de paix et
de silence que nous nous retrouvons pour
la dernière affiche donc c'est une image
de pommes qui représente
métaphoriquement en fait un anus c'est
un insoupçonnées devanture
qui peut
man est lui aussi
chacun en fait ce qu'il veut mais mais
il est également doté de plein de
terminaisons nerveuses et peut
participer activement à la vie sexuelle
et au plaisir o'keefe
[Musique]